so let's get the view from labor now
we're joined in the studio with Russian
Ali who also speaks on the treasury
select committee as well thanks very
much for being on the program hi how
much of a shock was it today when
inflation just didn't fall
it was a huge shock but in some ways
it's not uh surprising because what
we've seen is that the UK has got some
additional Dimensions to the crisis we
Face first of all other countries didn't
have the Liz truss mini budget Fiasco
which has had a direct impact on
people's mortgages it has led to a
follow-on budget where the new
Chancellor had has had to introduce a
consolidation package so that's quite
different from other countries and also
we entered into the pandemic with the
uncertainties around brexit with a trade
agreement that did leave outstanding
issues around supply chain disruptions
you know inflation food related food
price inflation is higher for us in
terms of what we import from the
European Union so there are some factors
that makes it harder for the UK but I
think uh the that overall I would say
that when you come compare the UK to
other countries on mortgages the UK is
worse off than France than Germany and
that I'm afraid is down to economic
mismanagement underpinned by political
instability that we've had in this
country for the last few years but
particularly the last year which has
consequences on the economy it's
obviously the easiest thing for labor
politically to blame the conceptors for
for this I'm not saying that that's not
there's no Factor at this time I mean
but I just wonder if there's also
something you could say about the way
that bank of England has handled it
right because there's people who say
that they were too slow to react to what
happened and so having to overcompensate
and also that they did pump an awful lot
of money into the economy through
quantitative easing and stuff as well
which has an information I'll come on to
that if you can't say if you can't if
labor if you think labor shouldn't call
I'm not saying that at all I don't know
I'm not saying that and I also allowed
you YouTube I I I'm absolutely not so
mad and also allowed you to make your
points but I'm just saying that okay the
difficult question
I guess is do you think this is partly
because of the bank of England as well
well I think that there is a there is a
certainly an issue about the point at
which quantitative easing should have
been phased out uh and some of us uh I
certainly raise those issues about
whether inflation was going to be
transitory which is what the governor of
the bank of England thought at the time
would happen his argument is that they
didn't see Ukraine coming they didn't
see the energy crisis coming but we and
you know we are much more vulnerable as
an economy because of the brexit
uncertainties and other factors that are
quite unique to the UK so yes one could
argue that uh with the benefit of
hindsight it would have been much better
for the bank of England to take action
earlier and phase in interest rates
gradually but we did have a major
pandemic uh I think the the other issue
though is that last year and it's not a
political point last year again we I
raised these issues at the treasury
committee before for the Liz trust
budget came it was very clear that if
she won she was going to go in the
opposite direction to the governor of
the bank of England in terms of trying
to bring inflation uh keep inflation
under control
and yet Liz truss was proposing a big
budget uh spend that was not it wasn't
clear how it's going to be funded and we
were arguing that these this Divergence
was very dangerous and there wasn't
enough called policy coordination what
we're seeing again is the current
government isn't actually being
coordinated enough with the bank of
England in terms of providing support to
mortgage mortgage holders they could do
they could be much more
assertive in working with the bank as
well as well it's not it's not
optimizing Independence and certainly
with The Regulators I'm just asking on
the because my understanding I'm I'm no
expert is if you trying to help people
with their mortgages then that is going
to be I mean that's kind of negates the
point right well you can do certain
things what you can do is make sure
first of all uh the government uh has
done very little
um and The Regulators haven't done
enough to make sure that Savers have the
uh the interest rates that the increase
in interest is passed on to Savers
that's about 23 billion a year if we're
serious about taking money out of the
economy uh and uh bringing inflation
down then the government needs the bank
of England and the financial uh conduct
Authority needs to be more assertive in
ensuring that Banks pass on those saving
rates to Savers because how would you
see that happen well I think there's a
role for the regulator to do that if and
also in terms of what the government
sets out and and
um encourages the the banks to do I know
that the chancellor is meeting the key
some of the major Banks later this week
he needs to make it very clear that we
expect to see along with the governor of
the bank of England and the head of of
the FCA we expect the interest rates to
be passed on to Savers because that
would help in terms of reducing the
money supply in the economy the second
thing is that the the the the FCA could
do more in terms of making sure that
they provide guidance to Banks about uh
spreading out mortgages over a longer
period of time now we need to be careful
that that doesn't then mean the actual
cost of borrowing in the long term is
born yet again by the the mortgage
holders but if we want to take mortgage
um if we want to prevent uh
repossessions then we do need to look at
ways in which the regulator can direct
Banks to be sensitive to repossessions
and make sure that they put in place
plans to support them if you look at the
amount of profits the banks have made
recently uh it's pretty phenomenal so
they could do more to prevent the
distress which would be damaging for
them as well if people face repossession
on a large scale really interesting to
talk thanks very much for being on the
program today